all right so this is breezy wasn't they
the key man character again buzz off
buzz off yeah which we think after
seeing him again I think it's very much
the Queen does I at the end seems very
buzz off hey man but we should pad this
is the first episode jason has not seen
ahead of time like all these episodes on
he's pretty much experiencing as we're
experiencing him so so it's kind of cool
so you can't prepare your comments or
anything okay I know you have before all
the time you should see our scripts I
mean it's like every little te ha ha no
you know that's all written 20 takes
just in the perfect laughs yeah so all
the time it's amazing how much we feel
so okeydoke so this episode Finn's arm
is not getting quote-unquote better it's
still flower and just doesn't know what
to do with it so dr. princess looks at
it and says that you need to feel better
you need to have fun they'll get it to
bloom and feel better so typical boy
logic he thinks well maybe if I make out
with a lot of girls that that'll make me
feel better you know not just one just a
lot no I said a lot of girls not your
wife that's the opposite I said with my
wife right there so so he goes around
and tries to take your stem will grows
pollinate so anywho so he Costa tries to
get all these princesses he comes across
a bee named brizi who really likes the
flower and thinks if she can impress him
maybe she can get with the flower so
she's sort of his wingman
and she puts it even though she said
to help him out and sure enough he's
getting with all these princesses at
least kissing the quote-unquote making
out which is really just a kiss and
finally gets to these all these are bees
are saying hey you can't do that you
can't hang with our going to be queen
bees so they all attack him and she
brings drinks the magic Queen juice or
whatever that was that jelly does this
pretty funny Sailor Moon transformation
it becomes this giant uber robotic we
people I thought of it more as honestly
uh Pokemon really very Pokemon s yeah
yeah Sailor Moon don't think do the
thing where it's like her body becomes
space or something like that like it's
like an outline or something that's like
space and planets in there or something
but yeah so so they she transforms and
now is the queen it confute control all
the bees and I say kiss my bow now she's
becoming Carmen it's selling the stuff
to animals is turn into the better view
are you're welcome anywho finally she
turns into a queen and they guest kinda
have to go their separate ways so he
tries to kill if want these Space
Princess alright she tried to get with
him they do something do one together
yeah well they weren't technically
together when we saw them but we do get
a disgusting disturbing close-up of LF
peas lips cuz she's on cuz remember
she's uh lifeguard oh yeah that's right
I'll be a life guy
and they just do something we don't know
what Finn doesn't seem to traumatize so
it can't I would think it's in a vault
yeah no that's true yeah just again in
the vault okay but even they didn't look
super traumatized before putting in the
vault so I'm just I had to hold on to
some hope um but the Queen comes and
they sing a song together and pretty
much makes it turn into a tree bloom and
gives him a new arm and she also gets
her flower and always good um I liked it
fine I mean it's like it's an okay
episode I really like the bee I like
breezy a wide I thought that was a very
cute character um and I also really
liked the opening when Finn is moping
because that seems very kid-like moping
when he's just on the bed and slumping
over and you know if a kid could walk
moping like how he did with his you know
his bodies are upside down like then the
legs moving and still I can't bend that
my yeah yeah you know a kid would you
know so it's I thought they got the kid
breathing very well come on you're gonna
try and make what oh my god you can't do
that no that's wrong stop it why don't
nobody stop this anyway oh okay he's
just giving me the keep going signal so
I guess we'll try I just think it keeps
going back over there it doesn't
understand that you get distracted makes
me a little bit I'm just gonna keep
doing that anyway well anyway what about
your voice oh voice the same voice yeah
the singing voice like daughters a
failure what we trying to do was see if
you can do it the finding you go Just
Answer you didn't have to like pull into
their room like it's you know I was
trying to let you go on and now you're
like you
or something Wow yeah woman doing good I
need to do it or doing a terrible job
okay it's you all are adorable flexible
trust me I know
and ya know I can explain the story
Breezies very cute I really like that
the voice actors were there was that the
singing voice is very nice I do why more
of that song I'm glad to came back at
the end but I was like the song they
were kind of singing at the beginning of
like it's a nice song yes I'm hoping it
would keep going um I think it's it's
definitely got some good last the whole
thing with her being more obsessed with
the flower you serve go okay she's a bee
whatever and I guess she gets the flower
in the end by make him happy whatever
it's a weird it's weird to get kind of
any emotional attachment to it cuz I
don't know we don't want flowers at
least not in the way that she wants a
flower so it's but she does say though
she does say I love your flower and also
you that's a little confuse to like I
don't know I feel like she she went
after him at first for his flower and
then being around him getting to know
him she started developing feelings for
him as well kind of like how he was
going after all the princesses just to
whatever it make out hey I want to cuz
you know I just think he'll make me feel
better but he doesn't really care much
about them as like a person or anything
if she kind of does for him eventually
eventually I that's what I got out of it
I guess I can see that I took it more as
kind of a it's I'm like a rebound thing
where you fall in love with something
about someone you don't fall in love
with that person you fall in love with
Oh their sense of humor or this Center
the other thing and I think that's kind
of was what it was with breezy breezy
fell in love with
flower of course obviously and over time
she thinks she liked him but in the end
you see she didn't fall in love with
Finn it was still the flower you know it
was he I don't want to see a face love a
piece of Finn
yeah it wasn't a fake love but it was no
in the end it was still the flower
that's what it was and that you can't
mask what you love and what you don't
love if you don't love something you
don't love that person you know even if
you love a part of them it doesn't mean
you love them as a whole boy that's so
much better than what I had you know
because Gracie was in love with like you
know think about it yeah I love ya I
love you flower
I mean fan yeah you know and in the end
if you know she takes the flower she
kisses it there could be the love for
Finn still but it doesn't I don't know I
saw more as she got the flower looks
like oh I don't mean Finn any more I got
actually what I really loved about Finn
yeah I agree with you on that I did feel
like that's what it was I feel like yeah
she developed feelings for him but in
the end she got the flower and then
she's like oh yeah I guess this is
really what I wanted after all yeah yeah
yeah that sounds right actually it
sounds really really right like Finn
Finn's going around trying to find
anything he can attach to with any of
these women and you know he's not
finding an actual love he's finding
things he likes about each of these you
know princesses and whatnot but it's not
actual love it's nothing concrete no I
actually I think that makes a lot of
sense and there's yeah kisses sort of an
interesting angle to take that you can
like something about somebody um it
might have made a little bit more sense
if she was kind of on the rebound to you
because we clearly know he was um I can
see it because you're right people can
confuse someone like you say with a
really good sense of humor it can be
really smart or something but it's not
necessarily love you know there's a lot
more to it as long as it is and bringing
up your stardom how many people have set
their insight up will you marry me you
see - yeah you seem to us
come up to Doug and said like oh I love
you and it's not like the obsession love
it's the hope I love you like they
actually do there's something about them
like about you that they do truly love
it's called a flower no there's what
this uh that knocking at account but the
count before the anime Midwest where
like this girl comes up and she's just
like it was very bizarre she's like
takes a picture everything and she said
it's get some weird but can I touch your
butt yeah and both Rob and I were there
it's like no is like you know the missus
are right right they're both our wives
were behind us in she's certain like oh
and she's about to leave and she's like
can I touch their butts no and
and Lily comes and I was just like oh I
think they would say no well can you ask
him I'm speaking for them they would say
no all right you know it's like it was
very bizarre um people can fall in love
with a character than an actor plays
they can fall in love with the way
someone looks but it's not the full
person hmm and yeah I'm probably reading
way too deep into this goddamn cartoon
but they kind of I mean I sort of saw
this one like you know I liked it but I
didn't fully get it but that that
doesn't really make sense honestly um
like I said the only thing that like it
says a little loss is that she also
wasn't on the rebound but I guess does
that always have to be rebound I mean
just some people don't know it's two
people that don't seem to really know
that much about love yeah you know and
feeling happy you know with a
quote-unquote loved one you know and if
both of them being confused kind of in
different ways you know cuz fan I don't
even think it's like learning the
personality he just want a girl yeah you
know where she very much wants him for
something that he has but she doesn't
realize you know that there's more to it
you know she's trying to convince her so
maybe I do love him because yeah I like
that one
no maybe there is more to and it's
trying to convince yourself that you
love a person when really there probably
isn't anything there you just trying to
convince yourself cuz you love that one
element you
you okay well um another thing I do want
to bring up which I thought was
interesting is I don't think this was
really about Finn trying to find a girl
what struck me the most was every time
he kept saying the same thing I feel
empty I just don't feel anything and I
feel like this was a really really
really great representation of
depression yeah it's way to bring it I
mean yes let her keep going actually I
do agree I don't I think it's a very
religious way honestly I just I thought
you know and it it's so many layers it's
really interesting too because on the
one hand on the surface yeah of course
he's looking for love he's lost flame
princess and that's part of it and he's
making out with the girls trying to find
that bless he wants to make himself feel
better but on the other end too
sometimes when you're all caught up in
this depression hole of a hell I don't
know you know you lose track of things
and you don't know and people are like
telling you cheer up you can do it it's
fine
it'll be great just do something nice
for yourself you know that sort of stuff
and I feel like he was trying and it was
like nothing was working I think he was
trying to distract himself and he was
trying to see even if he could feel
something I just for me personally I
felt over and over again I kept hearing
him say I feel empty I feel empty it
wasn't even he was so far into his
depression that he couldn't even feel
sad anymore he just couldn't feel it's
almost like an adult going on like an
alcoholic bender or a drug bender like
that's what he was doing
replaced it like drinking like crazy and
doing drugs with or having sex with
making out yeah if you replace making
out with any of those things that's so
good through a heart depression where
they're just destroying their lives
you're right I think I I mean that's a
really good way to look at it you're
trying to make yourself feel like
sometimes you
do and I'm sure a lot of you out there
you know have that experience where you
get to a point where you're so low
you're so terrifically low you don't
even know what to feel anymore yeah I
think there's just cans yeah I think
this into what you're talking about real
quick it's just throwing away he's gone
by the way if you really you're gonna
get something goofy now it's like okay
um but no I think you were talking about
replacing you know drugs and alcohol
with just making out with people and
stuff like that
I'd also you say I'd known a lot of
people both male and female who just
sort of think well I'm just gonna binge
on you know just sex partners yes stuff
like and I'll just make me feel better
and I've yet to see that work you know
it's you know and I've seen so many
people try over and over and over with a
lot of people in seven like I just yet
to see that you know that that's what
was missing sex with a stranger just
think like you know or just I just need
someone to like me you know some people
are tissa to to I need someone to like
me and I but I don't need it doesn't
matter who it is or if I'm friends with
our hey I just need a person you know
you don't need a friend you don't need a
companion don't need a loved one you
just need a person you know um you know
it might as well be just sort of a thing
you know to like me um so I think there
are times where yeah I mean I think just
as much as films now go I think it is an
addiction and yes it's prior to cure
something like you said that emptiness
and so you were talking about the you
know just a lot of people say go out
there have fun come on cheer up and
stuff like then I used to really think
that a lot of thing I that I know a lot
of people with depression and I would
always just go why don't you just be
happy come on like you know I was always
like it your life's fine you know what's
wrong and I realized more that it's very
much because depression is you know
clinical and is an imbalance that I
think it's something where you can know
what everything is fine but you don't
feel it yeah and that can be a really
really big difference and in a way that
makes it even worse because at least if
something goes wrong you can point to
certainty this is what's wrong I know I
had to go through the mourning process
or whatever but when you don't have
something solid that actually has
happened it's just an imbalance which
ins they just but it's an imbalance it's
harder to get a grasp on it it's harder
to understand therefore harder to
conquer well it's like a catch-22
because you're you're already feeling
this horrible feeling inside and then
logically you understand there's nothing
wrong my life is good but I'm not happy
and I'm so upset and I'm ashamed of this
and what's wrong with me and then you
get on yourself because to say what's
wrong with me that I can't feel happy
when I know I should and then you get
even more depressed because you know I
mean it's like you can't get out of it
it's a loop that is very very difficult
to kind of punch out of yeah no it's um
there was definitely but there's a weird
point when I realized I think it's
changed now but there was a point where
I realized I actually knew I had more
friends with depression than people who
did not have depression it was very
surreal what I thought about it and yeah
and it's one of those things so it's
like I definitely have you know like
experience I don't fake it open I don't
think I have depression I feel pretty
happy I feel good and stuff you know
even when I'm sad for periods of time
it's like okay that's being sad I know
there's a difference between being sad
and having depression um but yeah I
think there is something where cuz this
didn't come on the heels of breaking up
with somebody uh you know I mean granted
it he did so I have a little bit of a
closure with the father but that's not
the direct to think he's just he's going
through a lot yeah he and a lot of it
has not gotten it's gotten some closure
but it was few of them were ever very
happy you know yeah like that's okay but
kind of closure even along with his
father
you know he's come to grips with it but
he never heard him say anything you know
her Flame Princess never said you know
hey you know we're okay and things are
cool and usually feel happy you know
even Princess Bubblegum you know there's
been sort of you know sloppy moments
there and stuff so it's it's tough when
you really sort of looking at you don't
even need an explanation just sort of
get why he is this way so yeah honestly
yeah I went to this episode
like liking it okay but not fully having
it hit me but hearing all that I'm like
man it's pretty solid so that's more the
father talking about it um you know
that's why I like talking with people
about movies and not like you know no
you're wrong and here's what it's like I
like listening to this kind of stuff
gives you you learn all sorts of things
so yeah yeah well off of your whole
depressing depression crap I did like
when Jake showed up and it feels like
what's up with your head
I'm just trying something different yeah
we never know what that I like that I
like how Jake does bring up that frozen
yogurt princess looks like a combination
of PB and Flame Princess and Finn gets
all pissed off he's like no and I'm like
yeah that's kind of funny
and then notice after Finn gets his new
pant arm he's got a thorn yeah yeah
which I'm curious about yeah was it
still there again I know it's there
first thing I went away was it still
there
well though cuz he was there with all
the like sap or honey I'm not sure which
one I'm getting SAP and then all you do
is you see him shake his hand off it's
amazing it's still very I never see his
palm after that you see him go like that
yeah because that's about that too
yeah so well hopefully we'll find out
this one oh by the way forewarning for
the next episode this is another as far
as I know none canon episode with a
guest animator no I don't think it was
an April Fool's joke but be prepared
after what happened with the goddamn
glitches again I saw a sneak preview of
part of it and it's it's interesting so
be prepared so Howie poops yeah
thanks for giving that way now they know
what's on the couch you really are gonna
be fangirls and fanboys that have now
captured that
room I think I'm gonna do that my god